got amanda oh what recommend
um we'll take two on that
that was fun
this is gonna be a good one amanda oh
what are your recommendations for when
you feel down and depressed with your
comedy and writing
we all go through this amanda at every
single level um
even i remember when we interviewed nate
bargatzi on here
and he said after he records a comedy
special he feels like he's never going
to write another joke again
so even someone at his level goes
through
the self-doubt goes through that
critic that comes in critiquing
everything you're doing
i think what'll help what is the value
of hop breath pro
is having this like-minded community of
comics who understand where you're
coming from so i think
on just thinking of a a very like
simple like low effort
way to help when you're feeling down and
depressed about your comedy in your
writing
post it in this group and just let
people know hey i'm
feeling kind of down right now about x y
and z and i guarantee there are going to
be people in here that can relate to you
and have found ways to overcome it
themselves
um i'm re here is saying
he's like honestly just keep doing it i
can say that with writer's block
specifically
that even when i feel writer's block i
write anyway
and i show up anyway like i write 10
club is every single day
there's definitely days i felt like what
am i doing
i feel what's happening you know
why am i doing this type deal you know i
don't really feel like writing today and
things like that
but i show up anyway and i feel better
after and i may not have written a funny
joke that day
sometimes i have but um
it's all about just showing up even when
you don't feel like it and feeling like
action
action solves a lot if action solves
i was trying to think of some fun phrase
action is
action or whatever but really taking
action when you least feel like it is
actually
the most rewarding and most effective
way to get out of those funks
and having a supportive community like
here at hop breath pro
to kind of uses your supporting
your supporting community here when we
are feeling the highs we can celebrate
together and we're filling the lows we
can support each other in those
it's important to remember you're not
alone in this every at every single
level
people comics go through the highs and
lows and it's important to have
that supportive community around you
because we have seen
i mean at the most extreme examples but
we have seen
where that can or can take a comic if
they don't
um tap into that supportive community
they have access to
so at any point you're feeling alone
you're feeling like it's just you
struggling through this comedy journey
really post in this group or reach out
to
a fellow comic and just kind of get
their
insight you know just reach out to them
we're all here for each other
oh yeah that's a good example too
stephen stephen says
i usually try to watch or listen to
something that makes me happy
music videos of my niece stuff like that
finding your own happy place in a way
that's great too stephen yeah something
that makes you happy
watch it listen to it um go to that
account you know i look at um
i look at social media as part of like
my daily diet
of not only what i'm eating is part of
the diet but what i'm consuming
not only as food but consuming as i'm
like consuming on social media i look at
that as my daily diet and
i like to follow accounts that are
positive that are uh inspiring or that
do have helpful tips and things like
that things that i can
use to enlighten myself while i'm online
instead of just staring at donuts while
driving 80 miles an hour
down the highway which i do not do
anymore
breakthrough so um use that as well that
all that's all part of your mental
algorithm because what you
what you scroll becomes what you owe
i just made up that word because i
wanted it to rhyme but it really is like
you're a product to your environment at
every level
even on what you follow on social media
so if you have an account that cheers
you up
go visit that account yeah and that's a
good point bo when we did the q a with
jeff foxworthy he said he has moments
where he'll never be able to write again
and moments
after an album where he finds he could
have made a joke better
yeah so if we're talking about nate
bargatzi and jeff foxworthy having these
doubts
by all means amanda you're a comic
because you are
feeling these feelings so welcome to the
club
you're stuck now you're in a lifelong
club as don rickle said comics don't
retire they die
so sounds like you got the bug amanda
welcome welcome aboard that's why we
have hot breath pro
to be that supportive community
hey hop brother and sister if you
enjoyed this comedy tip
subscribe to this youtube channel and go
join
our facebook group to have your
questions answered live
on next week's q a